pierre compatible nos journées nos
pensées nos vies aujourd'hui sont
accaparés par la crise terrible que nous
traversons pour autant tout juste un an
après l incendie dramatique qui a ravagé
une partie de la cathédrale notre dame
de paris
je tenais à nouveau à remercier tous
ceux qui hier l'ont sauvé et tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui la reconstruisent nous
n'oublions rien ni l'héroïque élan de
courage qui a sauvé la cathédrale des
flammes ni la formidable vague de
générosité qui s'est levé dans les
heures et les jours qui ont suivi
je voulais donc redire aujourd'hui la
reconnaissance de la nation
d'abord envers nos soldats du feu qui
ont agi avec bravoure dans la nuit de la
110 ensuite envers les policiers les
agents du diocèse du ministère de la
culture de la mairie de paris de la
sécurité civile de la croix rouge qui
ont évacué la cathédrale sécuriser ses
alentours mis les oeuvres à l'abri
envers les 340 mille donateurs du monde
entier dont la générosité sera le ciment
de la splendeur retrouvée de notre dame
envers les compagnons et tous les
intervenants de ce chantier d'exception
enfin qui oeuvre depuis des mois assez
réédification nos architectes nos
artisans nous ouvriers ses compagnons
que je viens d'évoquer temps étant
d'apprentis qui seront mobilisés nous
reconstruirons notre dame en cinq ans
ai-je promis nous ferons tout pour tenir
ce délai bien sûr le chantier est en
suspens en ce moment du fait de la crise
sanitaire
mais il redémarrera dès que ce sera
possible
je ne crois pas que l'attentisme le
désarroi soit une réponse aux défis du
temps se fixer des objectifs
volontaristes
se mobiliser pour y parvenir être à la
hauteur des grandes constructions qui
ont fait notre histoire
c'est cette force d'âme qu'exigent les
temps présents il ya eu le temps de
l'épreuve et de l'émoi
puis le temps de la réflexion mais c'est
bien désormais le temps de la
reconstruction qui est engagée si la
restauration de notre dame nous importe
à tous c'est sans doute aussi parce
qu'elle est un symbole de la résilience
de notre peuple de sa capacité à
surmonter les épreuves et à se relever
c'est souvent dans l'adversité que nous
puisons les forces de fraternité qui
nous permettent de nous hisser ensemble
au dessus de nous mêmes à la hauteur de
l'histoire alors sauveteurs donateurs
bâtisseurs une nouvelle fois merci vous
avez pavé le chemin de ces jours
meilleurs qui approche où les français
retrouveront la joie d'être ensemble et
où la flèche de notre-dame s'élancera de
nouveau vers le ciel merci